falgha raketenangriff der russen auf ein
krankenhaus eine weitere furchtbare
nacht im krieg des kreml despoten putin
gegen die ukraine
dieses mal haben die russischen truppen
eine geburtsklinik mit ihren raketen
vernichtet das gebäude in der stadt
urmia rund 140 kilometer westlich von
kiew wird bei dem angriff massiv
zerstört auch ein wohnhaus in direkter
umgebung des krankenhauses wird
medienberichten zufolge getroffen
mindestens zwei menschen sterben 10
werden verletzt
unterdessen ist ein universitätsgebäude
in kharkiv bei einem angriff zerstört
worden wie ein berater des
innenministeriums meldet vermutet wird
dass das eigentliche ziel die
polizeistation gegenüber gewesen sein
soll
bereits am abend erschütterte in der
nähe von cardiff eine mega explosion die
nacht mit einer rakete soll eine
ehemalige panzer schule beschossen
worden munition explodiert seien allein
in kharkiv sind nach angaben des
bürgermeisters 21 menschen gestorben
mehr als 100 wurden verletzt
in der hauptstadt kiew bleibt es in der
nacht vergleichsweise ruhig am dienstag
hat das russische militär dort den
fernsehturm beschossen mindestens fünf
menschen kamen ums leben wie der
zivilschutz mitteilte
unterdessen bewegt sich der mehr als 60
kilometer lange militärkonvoi der russen
weiter auf kiew zu ist jedoch wohl durch
beschuss ins stocken geraten wie
informanten berichten aktuell ist der
konvoi noch 20 kilometer von kiew
entfernt wie bürgermeister vitali
klitschko gegenüber bild bestätigt